hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Chapter five of book one of his work
of stoic ethics on Duty's Cicero is
going to tell his son Marcus that
everything that is right everything that
is ho Ness them and we'll talk about
that term in just a moment
stems or arises from one of four things
those four things are actually going to
be the cardinal virtues of wisdom
justice courage and temperance and he's
going to characterize them a bit but we
want to dwell for a moment before we go
into that on this this term the hone s
them this this is the word that we get
honest and honesty from and it means
something that is good but not good
because it's only good for something
else it's not a useful good although it
certainly can be advantageous or useful
but it's not good primarily because of
that it's good intrinsically it is what
is good in itself so Cicero is is
interested here in clarifying the nature
and the origin of our duties that's why
it's the book on duties day of Ickes and
so he's saying that our duties are our
sense of moral oughtness
are our you know rightness our
conception of that arises from these
these four sources and we may be mixed
up about this but if we think it through
he thinks that we're going to arrive at
these and that will you know by
examining them analyzing them seeing
what wisdom what justice what courage
what temperance really include an
encompass we'll be able to figure out
how we ought to run our lives remember
that one of the goals of the the book on
duties is to provide us with the rules
by which we can attain the highest good
for ourselves the Summum bonum or the
you know penis bone or um the the the
end of
the the the some the highest good so
each of these is going to be
characterized in a certain way when he
tells us in this this paragraph that
everything right arises the word that
he's using there is is oratory it stems
from it arises from it has its origin in
and he doesn't actually name the virtues
at that point although of course it's in
the back of his mind what he tells us
instead is what the what the type of
activities or the type of concerns would
be that would would give us the the
right so he tells us that one of these
is what he calls the what we're
translating here is the full perception
and handling of true or of the truth and
so he says in Pearce the kit Pearce pick
entia a very celerity Quay right so a
concern for right a handling of the
truth and in full like you know entire
looking around full understanding of
what is true not just you know grasping
a fact and being done with it
but grasping how the facts are related
to each other and we'll talk about that
a bit more then he names three things
that fit into the you could say basket
of justice
he says conserving human society
literally the Society of human beings so
sookie itas lumen eorum right giving
each what they deserve this is a
traditional conception of justice and
then the faithful fulfillment of the
things that we have agreed to or a
little bit more literally things that we
have contracted for each of those is
something that we ought to do right so
that's one of these four sources then he
talks about the greatness and the
strength of a noble spirit and now this
is not necessarily what we would
associate with cur
but for the Stoics and for cicero what
we can call great mindedness is is
connected with courage there's more
involved and courage as we're gonna see
but this is the way that he frames it
here and then he talks about the order
ordinay and moderation modo of what is
said and done and so each of these
yields us when we when we put it
together we said well what actually
provides us with that as a possibility
you know the truth and seeking the truth
trying to understand it from all sides
that's wisdom and wisdom is what
accomplishes that these other things you
know conserving human society giving
each what it what is due to them
faithful fulfillment of agreements that
is justice the greatness and strength of
a noble spirit courage order and
moderation of what is said and done
temperance and so he goes on and he adds
a little bit more explanation for each
of these in this this chapter and I
think it's worth dwelling on that
because this helps us flesh out our
understanding of what these four sources
are so he goes on and he says you know
we the one that we designated first
wisdom and prudence so Sapientia and
prude NC a-- he says these belong to the
search after truth and it's discovery
right the the seeking out and the
finding of truth and he you know he goes
on and adds a little bit more to this
and he says you know the more that one
seeks out truth the more quickly and
accurately can I see and explain the
reasons the more understanding and wise
he's generally esteemed and justly so so
this virtue is particularly concerned
with truth this virtue justice is
concerned with other things he says once
again these three remaining virtues they
have the task of providing and
maintaining the things of which the
practical business of life depends so
that the relations of human being to
human being
human society can be conserved this is a
key idea for a Cicero justice is not
just about following rules it's not just
about making sure that you follow
through on your contract it's not just
about giving everybody what they deserve
there's also this other aspect of making
sure that we further human society that
we hold it together that we further the
social you could say desire or instinct
of human beings which stems from our
very rationality he goes on and he also
talks about this largeness and nobility
of soul that we fighting courage he says
it can be revealed not only in
increasing one's resources and acquiring
advantages for oneself and one's family
but far more in rising superior to those
things so that's a very interesting
thing to say and it's also typically
stoic courage involves you know not just
having a high spirit or something like
that but in applying it and using it so
as to acquire the things that are
needful for life often against
resistance often through difficulty
often facing challenges but it also
involves rising above even those and
treating them as what they are really
worth which is not as much as having a
virtue then finally the the fourth
source he goes on and expands by saying
orderly behavior in consistency of
demeanor and self-control these have
their place in that Department of things
in which a certain amount of physical
exertion and not mental activity merely
is required and he says if we bring a
certain amount of propriety and order
into the transactions of daily life we
will be conserving Honus totem this this
you know goodness in itself and decos
what is what is befitting what is
dignified what what we ought to do so
each of these taken individually is part
of what we ought to do Cicero says that
they kind of interpret
trade each other but we can also
consider each of them separately which
is what he is going to do in in the
further chapters but we should think
about all of them as in some sense
encapsulating and encircling everything
that is genuinely right so what this
means is we can rely on the virtues for
understanding what it is that we human
beings ought to do
you